we had an active shooter that happened
at the Mercy Hospital in Chicago there
was a doctor working that ER she got
into a domestic with her fiance she
wanted to break up with him so he's like
okay let's break up meet me out in the
front give me back my ring he called her
she came out she gave back her ring and
you pulled out a pistol and he killed it
right there it's showing the camera he
stood in front of her body Cox Carstar
company started shooting at the cops car
then he ran inside the hospital and he
shot these two I don't know their nurse
they were just getting out of the
elevator and he shot one of them dead
there was an officer there named officer
Jimenez doing some kind of paperwork he
only had like a couple years on the job
he hurt the gunfire one of my team
members he was a sniper and officer
amendez bound across to the next area of
cover the dude stuck the gun around and
shot and one of the rounds hit officer
Jimenez riding a juggler and he bled and
died at that very moment and I guarantee
you when he woke up that morning before
he put on a uniform the last thing he
thought it was that he's going to die in
that hospital especially just doing
paperwork in the hospital you don't
think you know